we have the possibility of of winning
this time but win or lose there's no
doubt in my mind that Biden or whatever
the Democratic candidate is just in case
he's not we you know it's not official
yet but the I Hillary won by three
million votes in the popular vote as we
call it I think Biden he'll win by five
million I think a lot of people are
going to come out that that stayed home
mistakenly last time they're gonna come
out this time but I think Trump could
still win the electoral college and so
all of us have to be really in fighting
mode because he is and he he knows he
knows his people so he just has to he
will get all that 44 46 percent of he
just needs a couple more percent of the
people who on his side who stayed home
last time yeah so and he's so up upfront
about how the less people vote the
better it is for Republicans he
literally said if we had more people
voting you'd never have a Republican in
this country elected again that's not
the subtext of what he said that is
actually what he said you got to give it
to this guy he does speak his inner
monologue yes and that's and that's why
if you listen to him and if you take him
at his word understand that he is a lot
of the time telling the truth not the
greater truth right his truth he
believes that he'd pass a lie-detector
if you if he wired him up and and he's
right if if we make it easy for people
to vote if we don't have voter
suppression Republicans you're gonna
lose because the majority of the country
does not support the Republican agenda
the majority of the country are not
climate deniers the majority of the
country believes women should be paid
the same as men the majority of the
country go down the whole list the
majority of the country takes the
liberal center-left
Democratic Party position on most issues
so so the only way Republic
kids can win and this has been true now
for a few elections is too cheap is to
somehow game it rig it do whatever they
need to do in this case what I'm worried
about bill is that last time remember he
threatened that he kept saying the whole
elections gonna be rigged and you know
PR Mikey what did he he said my second
amendment people I appealed to my second
amendment people the gun people to get
ready because this is gonna be a rigged
election and the funny thing is is that
what he actually thought was he was
certain he would win the popular vote
because of course everybody who loves
him that's what a malignant narcissist
would believe but he was worried that
the Clintons were somehow going to rig
the electoral college and that's how he
was gonna lose this time he he doesn't
even have to he's already got his gun
guys the guys with the guns in we saw
this in Michigan the last couple of
weeks showing up at the State Capitol
with her long their long arms and
threatening everybody to the point where
the governor last Thursday just shut the
legislature down called the day off was
so afraid this is this is my I want to
appeal to people to not be afraid of
these guys with the guns I went to high
school with him I know them they they
want to kill Bambi that's their idea of
a real fight them and a deer if if the
deer were ever armed if they if it was a
fair fight
these guys would never be in the woods
it's so important that liberals who
generally are not gun owners not be
afraid because that's all they're trying
to do now liberate Michigan liberate
Minnesota you know good good on all of
you for showing up with those guns he's
just trying to scare liberals because
liberals get scared easy don't be scared
you know we are the majority there's
more of us than there are of them the
only way that they're going to pull it
off is somehow he's able to cancel the
election or postpone it that is what we
have
to fight against because I'm certain
that's what's going on in his head right
now well one way he wants to rig the
vote is he's kind of declared war on the
post office because for example Michigan
sent out ballots last week to everybody
and Trump his response was to threaten
to withhold kovat aid to the state of
Michigan in response which of course
sounds to me like the exact same
playbook from Ukraine withholding aid
that's one of his big tricks except this
is our country
you